what was the most embarrassing loss
of your career
i had so many flashbacks but i'm so glad
it's a question for andrea i like that
you specified
you know it's funny because
i mean because you said you're so
competitive and like yeah no i could
tell just even from the way you said it
that like you hate losing i yeah i mean
that was the reason i hated chess in
high school because it'd always be like
but okay there's many traumatizing
losses where if you're like you're top
three you're running for first and then
you throw a game you shouldn't but and
this shouldn't hurt my ego as much as it
does
um but it's always kids
or when i was a high school girl it's
the younger boys who are really cocky
and when they win they start rubbing it
in your face and they're yawning and
looking around when like
90 of the game you were destroying them
and you had this one tiny mistake and
now their ego is huge um but i'll never
forget i was playing like for a chess
scholarship um and i was it was
tiebreaker for first and i think i lost
to a 12 year old girl who couldn't even
use the scholarship but she beat me in
one first place and she got some other
prize
um so yeah i was losing to that little
girl who's literally like 2 300 now so
makes sense right you keep telling
yourself that what do you think because
do you think caspar was feeling that
when he was playing 13 year old magnus
like yeah why as much as it's a beauty
of the sport that any age can be
brilliant any demographic anything
um i feel like when you're adult and
you're paired against the kid it's just
hard not to let it get to you and it
depends maybe if they're a really sweet
kid but most times i play kids they're
just really arrogant and but i don't
think they do it intentionally because
they're kids i mean there is a certain
etiquette thing where like like you said
yawning and in general like it's not
kids there's no etiquette yeah yeah
yeah the kids traumatized me too i was
playing in vegas and
it was not even my opponent it was the
board next to me and the kid was at
least 10 years old made 12 max and he
was playing against an adult and he
takes out his hand and he starts doing a
fake phone to which the kid studying
sitting across diagonally picks up their
banana and starts talking like it's a
phone and they're just mouthing words
why their two adult opponents are
thinking intensely at the game and then
i see the adult look up look at the kid
just making bananas and then destroy his
eyes as he sighs
yeah and they're not even doing for
trash talking no no they're just
bored kids yes exactly what was the
because you you played a bunch of uh
people for for your channel uh what was
the most like memorable what's the most
fun most intense
there's a bunch of fun ones you've
played kids before some trash talking
kids that sounds great they trash talk
kids yeah nothing like losing a 12 year
old who then starts doing a fortnight
dance yeah
so that that actually happened that did
happen he he is uh you know a very young
master i think he became master when he
was like nine years old or something and
he's very good at chess and doing a lot
of training but he's also incredibly
good at trash talking and he beat me one
game and he stood up and he started
doing the fortnite dance
so you know you gotta just swallow your
pride in those moments
you